didier guillaume le vice-président
socialiste du sénat et président du
conseil général de la drôme est l'invité
de preuves par 3 ici au salon de
l'agriculture bonsoir monsieur kg et
merci d'être avec nous dans ce lieu qui
est également le dernier salon où l'on
cause je vous ai vu en grande
conversation ici avec bada pour le
président de la république et puis et
puis le premier ministre
d'ailleurs françois hollande est reparti
du stand de la drôme avec un olivier
c'est votre cadeau vous pensez qu'il va
le planté dans le jardin de l'elysée
j'espère bien en tout cas c'est ce que
je lui ai demandé il a dit qu'il le
ferait
lolivier c'est l'arbre des rois c'est
l'arbre des dieux ça porte bonheur c'est
mythologiques et puis ça produit aussi
des olives qui sont formidables mais
c'est un symbole multiforme un de
longévité d'espérance été choisi pour
cela aussi exactement du salon n'est pas
seulement le salon où l'on cause c'est
aussi celui où l'on vit où on rencontre
la vraie france les vrais gens celles et
ceux qui travaillent durement à la
campagne et puis les visiteurs qui
veulent se rappelent se rappeler soit
leur enfance soit tout simplement pour
les enfants de la région parisienne
voire une vache voir un une brebis donc
c'est un lieu passionnant alors
l'espérance vous l'avez 10 l'olivier on
en a besoin aujourd'hui indique
guillaume le le changement ça n'est pas
pour tout de suite au niveau du chômage
qui a encore augmenté pour le 21e mois
consécutif et il est au plus haut là ce
soir
depuis 1997 oui c'est dramatique
et je voudrais vraiment et c'est pas un
fait de discussions mais avoir une
pensée pour les trois millions de nos
concitoyens qui sont au chômage et ce
soir on va attendre les chiffres mais
vraisemblablement ça va encore beaucoup
augmenter trop augmenter et sur 1,4 par
rapport à décembre là et aussi ceux qui
sont dans la précarité c'est
insupportable et tous les gouvernements
qui se sont succédé ont essayé de
résorber le chômage
mais nous sommes dans une spirale dans
une crise européenne dans une crise
mondiale mais quand même est-ce que le
président de la république a été
imprudent quand il a parié sur une
inversion de la courbe ici la fin de
l'année didier guillaume non ce n'est
pas de l'imprudence et du volontarisme
c'est du volontarisme parce que ce qu'il
faut
la première des priorités la toute
première des priorités c'est de lutter
contre le chômage c'est de redresser
notre pays dans la justice c'est de
faire ensemble en sorte que nos comptes
publics soient équilibrés sans cela
point de salut alors nous allons en
parler un peu plus tard dans cette
émission avec eux suzette bloch notre
partenaire de l' agence france-presse
avec dailymotion également qui nous suit
chaque semaine on va évoquer donc
l'impasse économique et budgétaire du
gouvernement
comment appliquer une rigueur de gauche
mais nous direz tout à l'heure si vous
êtes pour ou contre de nouveaux impôts
tient pour les français et puis enfin
perrine tarneaud de public sénat nous
rejoindra à la fin de cette émission
pour vous interroger sur le sénat à
l'introuvable majorité pour le
gouvernement donc nous sommes ici on l'a
dit didier guillaume dans une vitrine
votre département compte plus de 7000
exploitants agricoles est ce que vous
sentez cette défiance entre les
producteurs et les consommateurs
lorsqu'on est dans un département rural
un petit département on le sent un peu
moins parce qu'on sait que par les
circuits courts par les marchés fermiers
parlée par les marchés on arrive à
rencontrer ces gens-là
mais ce que je sens aujourd'hui et suite
à ce qui vient de se passer avec la
fameuse affaire de la viande de cheval
c'est qu'il y a une véritable défiance
je pense qu'il faut absolument que
l'agriculture française que les
industries agroalimentaires que les
producteurs artistes le lien le meilleur
possible
je le disais en introduction tout à
l'heure les français aiment leurs
paysans aiment leurs agriculteurs
salariés regardent un peu différemment
maintenant vaches et surtout surtout les
rimes et je crois qu'ils les regardent
les industriels devront regarder ferment
ce qu'ils consomment et je pense qu'il
faut vraiment faire la différence entre
l'excellent travail
les excédents de production faite par
les exploitants agricoles de notre pays
et puis qu'est-ce qui se retrouve dans
l'assiette et sur votre les choses sont
en adéquation
alors il ya une chose qui est simple il
faut aller de la fourche à l'assiette
il faut aller du producteur que vous
avez déjà mis à
avec des produits de qualité nous
essayons nous avec nous sommes premier
département bio de france mais au delà
un travaillant sur les circuits courts
avec ce que l'on appelle à gries locale
c'est pour mettre en place la
d'équations entre les producteurs et les
consommateurs le plus possible
aujourd'hui dans cette affaire dite de
la viande de cheval
cet intermédiaire entre le départ et
l'arrivée dans une assiette ce n'est pas
possible ça c'est l'ultra libéralisme
c'est les profits à tous crins noms
revenant à la base revenant aux
fondamentaux
revenons à l'histoire de notre
agriculture ce sont des exploitants qui
produisent pour nourrir le plus
correctement possible et ce sont surtout
aujourd'hui vous le constatez peut-être
dans votre département des exploitants
qui souffrent oui ils souffrent ils sont
inquiets ils souffrent parce que pendant
de nombreuses années les revenus n'ont
pas été là il sauve parce qu'il ya eu de
nombreuses crises des crises sanitaires
des crises climatiques et tout cela ça
le ça ne règle pas ça ne se règle pas
encore et ils souffrent parce qu'ils
sont dans l'inquiétude parce
qu'aujourd'hui ils ont l'impression que
l'europe n'est pas là pour les soutenir
et là pour empêcher 5 ans elian leur ré
expliquer justement ce que vous venez
très bien de dire que la grande victoire
obtenue par la france par le président
de la régie pratique c'est une demande
et moi je vous dis les subventions
agricoles ont été sauvegardés pour la
france et oui mais c'est très important
nous sommes un des rares pays à avoir
ces subventions se retient de lui c'est
important il faisons l'ancien membre de
l'union européenne
elle est là pour les aider notamment
dans l'es2 puis les piliers de la
politique agricole commune
est-ce que
les subventions de la politique agricole
commune sont indispensables à la survie
des exploitants dans votre département
elles sont indispensables assuré le
doigt les eau en diminuant vous le savez
vous leur avez dit non ils vont pas
aller en diminuant au fil des années
devant nous ah bah ça nous verrons bien
en tout cas sur les cinq ans qui
viennent
en euros constants ce sont les mêmes
aides que dans la précédente politique
agricole commune
simplement il faut les répartir
différemment comme aurait dit ma grand
mère il ne peut pas pleuvoir toujours où
c'est mouillé
il faut que les aides aillent à ceux qui
en ont le plus besoin c'est la
redéfinition que nous allons mettre en
place les aides directes du premier
pilier avec les cinq langues pour la
prime aux 50 premiers hectares c'est un
peu technique mais c'est bien vous vous
craignez rien en disant ça parce que je
suis vous n'y a peut-être pas de grands
céréaliers
non mais c'est passé la question j'ai
des céréaliers moi j'ai des semences et
dans mon département oui mais
aujourd'hui force est de constater qu'il
faut réorienter les aides de la
politique agricole commune allant vers
l'élevage qui souffrent beaucoup vers lé
petit exploit les exploitations et
lorsque les budgets sont contraints mais
il faut que certains est un petit peu
moins pour d'autres et plus et puis s'en
sortir c'est une question de survie
alors j'ai une question sur les éleveurs
dans votre département à propos des
loups il vous êtes engagé un auprès
d'eux
il y à un nouveau plan loup qui a été
lancé qui va être lancée au printemps
est ce que à votre connaissance c'est un
peu tôt pour le dire mais certains ont
déjà utilisé le droit de tirer par
exemple sur sur les animaux sauvages non
pas encore parce que c'est pas vraiment
la saison encore oui les ce plan loup a
été plutôt bien a bien apprécié à titre
personnel je trouverai toujours qu'il ne
va pas assez loin
il a été assez apprécié là peut-être
trop loin pour les défenseurs des
louanges
non il n'y a plus de problème de
surpopulation des loups il ya 200 loups
environ en france
moi je vais vous dire une chose michel
grossiord il faut faire un choix dans
votre pays et moi le choix il est fait
il y as incompatibilité entre le
pastoralisme et le loup donc si on veut
qu'il y ait encore des supprimes alors
alors il faut pas qu'ils le loup et le
plan loup qui a été mise en place
vent dans ce sens-là ya des tirs de
défense et est ce qu'on appelle des
prélèvements je pense que là où il ya
d'un élevage
il faut tirer le loup pour l'empêcher
d'être un prédateur dans mon département
oui c'est plus de 400 brebis qui ont été
égorgés moi j'ai vu des éleveurs en
détresse qui pleure
il n'élève pas des brebis des ovins pour
les voir égorgé et là il faut être clair
mais le plan loup va dans le bon sens
les responsables agricoles me l'ont dit
ne baissons pas la garde
il ne faut pas opposer les défenseurs de
l'environnement avec les éleveurs et les
défenseurs de l'environnement les
écologistes n'ont pas pesé sur le
gouvernement ils n'ont pas remporté
cette victoire sur le loup je ne sais
pas puisque c'est une grande victoire
pour les éleveurs de dire qu'il ya des
tirs de défense et de prélèvements je
pense que c'est incompatible sur un même
territoire le loup et les drêches voilà
pour la cohabitation donc entre les
éleveurs et les dangers pour la
biodiversité
il y aura encore beaucoup de loup il y
en a environ 200 aujourd'hui il y avait
zéro dans les années 40
on a 200 aujourd'hui je pense qu'il n'y
a pas de problème vu que vivre dans la
drôme cellou et de cohabitation sur
lesquels j'aimerais vous interrogez vous
avez dit que la drôme était le premier
département bio oui comment est-ce que
vous cohabiter avec des centrales
nucléaires mais c'est ça n'a pas rien à
voir et à premier département bio nous
le promouvant nous essayons 14 % de la
surface agricole utile et cultivées en
bio dans le département ces 2 % au
niveau national
moi je suis pour l'excellence
l'excellence dans l'industrie
l'excellence dans l'agriculture
le nucléaire est une industrie
d'excellence et je pense qu'il faut
absolument continuer nous en avons
encore besoin et continue à défendre
cette industrie
même si dans les engagements du
président de la république il ya la
baisse de 75 à 50% dans notre mix
énergétique et même s'il va falloir
aller vers la transition écologique
c'est évident mais le bio c'est aussi
l'excellence et accessoirement ça permet
aux producteurs d'avoir des revenus un
peu supérieurs et par les temps qui
courent c'est quelque chose de très
important mais la défense du bio et de
l'agriculture de l'exploitation des
terres en surface est ce que c'est les
raisons qui vous amène à
à prendre peut-être position contre
l'exploitation des gaz de schiste ou
est-ce que votre position évoluer dans
ma position n'a absolument n'a pas
évolué je suis très opposé à
l'exploitation des gaz de schiste j'ai
fait partie des manifestations
citoyennes dans mon département nous la
moitié du territoire de la drôme est
concerné jamais je ne soutiendrai ceux
là par contre que la recherche avance et
que l'on regarde s'il devait y avoir de
nouvelles techniques alternatives non
polluantes
on verra bien ils ne fermaient pas la
honte je suis des jeux mais je suis très
curieuse et ont collé aux actions des
gaz de schiste au jour d'aujourd'hui
mais j'ai voté la loi au sénat
quand on empêche les chercheurs de
chercher ça peut assez vite aller vers
l'obscurantisme et moi je suis un homme
éclairé et je suis content
l'obscurantisme donc laissons faire les
chercheurs
nous verrons bien ce n'est pas le moment
pour l'instant la loi elle éclaire pain
d'exploration d'exploitation s'énonce
pour tout de suite mais oui peut-être
demain c'est la position du chef de
l'état cru peut-être qui a évolué sont
des sujets un peu d'orange ou non je ne
crois pas je crois que depuis le début
nous avons dit non à une exploitation du
gaz de schiste qui taperait dans leur
ruche mère qui ferait des dégâts et
riblon dans notre sous sol maintenant
nous verrons bien s'il ya d'autres
techniques mais vous avez une chose les
choses évoluer les choses évoluent
toujours dans son jour des gens donc
vous savez quand même envie d'exploiter
ses richesses dans le sous-sol de la
drôme
on ne sait pas si c'est des richesses on
ne savait pas vraiment combien il y
aurait il ya de mètres cubes
tout ce que je sais moi je suis un homme
de progrès et tout ce qui va dans le
sens du progrès est à l été est
important donc continuons comme cela
voilà alors vidé guillaume aurait donc
évoqué maintenant la situation du pays
on a déjà commencé en ayant un premier
mot bien sûr sur la dégradation de
l'emploi dans notre pays
suzette bloch de l' agence france-presse
va nous rejoindre d'abord on va voir
avec fabrice qu'une lé pari difficile de
françois hollande on l'a dit sur le
chômage mais y en a d'autres bien sûr
celui de ramener le déficit à 3% cette
année qui ne sera pas tenu d'autres noms
plus aisé que devient la dépense
publique sont inévitables nous avons
commencé en faire nous continuerons à en
faire non seulement au sein du budget de
l'état mais également au sein des
opérateurs au sein des différentes
politiques publiques des économies
encore des économies toujours des
économies
6 milliards à trouver en 2014 pour
contenter bruxelles et ramener le
déficit à 3 % françois hollande a
prévenu ce week-end il faudra réduire la
dépense publique et trouver de nouvelles
recettes fiscales
un tunnel de rigueur que ne partage pas
une partie du ps emmanuel maurel et son
courant maintenant la gauche critique
par exemple ce diktat européen
regardez en grèce + 50 % des jeunes sont
au chômage en italie près de 40%
est ce que c'est ce modèle là qu'on veut
pour pour les français et est ce que
finalement on est d'accord avec ce
discours un peu bizarre qui consiste à
dire l'europe deviendra plus riches
une fois que tous les européens seront
devenus pauvres moi je ne crois pas
c'est pour ça que nous préconisons avec
avec beaucoup d'autres un une vraie
relance au niveau européen et de toute
façon au niveau français
les partisans de la relance compte leurs
ministres delphine batho arnaud
montebourg ou encore cécile duflot des
ministres qui ne cachent plus leur
inquiétude
personne ne peut croire que de
l'austérité naîtra des temps meilleurs
alors rigueur on relance le débat anime
aussi les parlementaires de la majorité
pour françois patriat la france n'aurait
pas le choix et doit tirer les leçons du
passé
rouvrir les vannes on a fait ça par le
passé on sait où cela nous a mené moi je
me souviens même de la période 81 83
j'étais à l'époque parlementaire déjà je
sais où ça les a menés après un tournant
difficile avec des mesures encore plus
dur il faut mieux prendre des mesures
dures aujourd'hui que d'une mesure
demain insoutenable reste que ce matin
en réunion du groupe socialiste au sénat
le ton est monté
certains parlementaires s'inquiètent de
l'impact d'un nouveau tour de vis
budgétaire de l'impact sur l'électorat
de gauche
le ministre des relations avec le
parlement dédramatise la contestation à
monsieur mise d'être venu faire accepter
le tournant de la rigueur au sénateur
socialiste jour pas pourquoi vous poser
cette question est lancée dans ces
termes là il n'y a pas de tournant il ya
le cap
continuer et le cap du redressement des
comptes de la france telle que nous
l'avons trouvée lorsque nous avons gagné
les élections
preuve d'un certain malaise père
moscovici est lui aussi venu défendre la
politique du gouvernement devant les
sénateurs
pas de nom sous lequel les annonces de
ce week-end ne serait donc qu'un
événement est pas question de parler de
politique d'austérité devant les
sénateurs la rigueur un tabou qui
passent de plus en plus difficilement
auprès d'une partie de la majorité
voilà un sujet de blocs donc de l'
agence france presse nous a rejoint un
bon soir sujette votre première question
à 18 guillaumin soit monsieur didier
guillaume alors comment jugez vous les
premiers mois de la politique économique
du gouvernement
tous les voyants sont au rouge chômage
déficit de croissance
la faute uniquement la crise tous les
voyants sont au rouge est en avance
parce que rien ne serait pire que de
faire du statu quo que d'être d'être à
l'arrêt la politique économique mise en
place par le président de la république
et par le gouvernement elle est claire
ce n'est pas une politique d'incantation
aujourd'hui les caisses sont quasiment
vides en retrait oui mais elles sont en
retrait comme ils le sont depuis dix ans
comme il le sent depuis cinq ans il ya
eu alternance wii u alternance est alors
la crise mais elle n'a pas connu
l'alternance parce que si l'alternance
avait balayé la crise ça nous aurait
arrangé malheureusement ça n'a pas été
le cas
moi je constate qu'il ya d'un côté une
ancienne majorité qui joue les pompiers
pyromanes
c'est à dire qu'ils ont allumé les feux
tous azimuts et maintenant ils
voudraient nous expliquer comment les
éteindre
non il ya de l'autre côté une partie de
la gauche qui dit il faut redistribuer
les redistribuer quoi redistribuer ce
que l'on n'a pas non et la position du
président de la république et du
gouvernement
6 milliards supplémentaires à trouver en
2014 alors que faut-il faire début mais
ça bien sûr je n'étais pas de ce que
vous pensez que les français les vrais
gens comme
dit pour un supporter une nouvelle cour
de séries télé pour l'instant n'est pas
à l'austérité moi je ne veux pas que
l'on rajoute 0 0 8e
il ne faut pas rajouter l'austérité à la
récession il faut être
il faut avoir du volontarisme cette
crise elle est là les 6 milliards je ne
sais pas si c'est 5 6 et si c'est ça
c'est le volontarisme pour l'instant
c'est la série tout simplement nous
sommes dans une crise très profonde dans
l'europe que tous les pays sont touchés
que nous espérions qu'il y ait un rebond
le rebond n'est pas venu et que
l'objectif prioritaire nous en parlions
tout à l'heure c'est la lutte contre le
chômage pour la relance économique et
les mesures qui ont été mises en place
par françois hollande et son
gouvernement vont dans cette direction
c'est qu'une nouvelle hausse d'impôt
serait inévitable j'espère qu'elle sera
évitables votre association avec
j'espère qu'elle sera réparé
parce que mettront peut-on augmenter
encore leurs concitoyennes en peuvent
plus ils n'en peuvent plus de la
fiscalité locale
ils n'en peuvent plus de la fiscalité
nationale d'autant plus que ces
dernières années reconnaissons quand
même que la fiscalité nationale
elle était mal mis en place il y avait
d'un côté le bouclier fiscal qui a coûté
très cher au pays et d'échecs rembourser
aux plus riches
et puis il y avait les plus pauvres qui
paient les accords mais aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui aujourd'hui que
la vie des français meilleure la vie des
français n'est pas meilleur aujourd'hui
bien sûr que non mais attendez madame
françois hollande a été élu le 6 mai
dernier
nous sommes au début de l'année 2013
huit ou neuf mois après le programme
c'est sur cinq ans le redressement des
finances dans la justice c'est sur cinq
ans nous préférerions que ça ait pu dire
qu'il va y avoir cinq années difficiles
et j'espère que non puisque la position
du président de la république était
clair c'est de dire dans un premier
temps je redresse et après je
redistribue j'entends ce que disent
certains de mes amis projet mais on ne
peut pas redistribuer ce que l'on n'a
pas moi dans ma famille on m'a toujours
appris on fait des économies et après on
peut acheter des choses mes proches je
ne sais pas ce que dit aujourd'hui
stop aux impôts on entend ce discours
aussi au parti socialiste harlem désir
bien sûr mais mais claude bartelone bien
le président de l'assemblée nationale
qui diront on ne peut plus rien demandé
aux français est ce que vous dit la même
chose je pense que les français ont
assez payé
parfois pour des errements pour leurs
impôts et qu'il faut faire en sorte
d'équilibré les
les comptes en réduisant la dépense
plutôt qu'en augmentant encore les
impôts des français nous avons fait
ouvernement de tenir sa promesse de
stabilité financière absolument en même
temps la crise est là et peut-être il
faudra que les efforts ciblés
vous savez la précédente loi de finances
avec la réforme fiscale a déjà augmenté
les impôts de 7 milliards et demi alors
mieux répartis ce qu'ils ont plus avec
la la tranche qui a été rajouté etc
mais il n'empêche qu'aujourd'hui ça pèse
pour toutes les taxes exceptionnelles
mois sur les ondes sur les revenus plus
là la tranche la tranche 2 45% qui a été
rétablie
on demande des efforts à tout le monde
en parle de gabegie des collectivités
vous sans vous être coupable comme
président du conseil général de la drôme
est ce que vous pensez comme qu'est ce
qu'on peut étonner miser sur les
collectivités territoriales
je vais pas vous poser une question mais
quand vous dites on parle qui parlent
bien qu'on défonce horizon la cour des
comptes dit pas qu'il a une gabegie du
packaging comme un pays comme l'a
annoncé d'ailleurs le ministre du budget
récemment que dans l'effort qui va être
demandé à la france entière et les
collectivités locales doivent elles
mêmes colonnes ont été chiffrés pour les
connexions va parler avec vous bien sûr
des débats qu'a milliards cinq cent un
milliard cinq cent mille euros par an le
précédent gouvernement avait annoncé
deux milliards c'est un milliard cinq
nous n'étions pas contents ce soit
annoncé les deux milliards nous ne
sommes pas plus content aujourd'hui qu
on nous prélève un milliard 5 mai mais
vous parce que l'eau se faire au
détriment de l'investissement les
justement parce que nous sauver parce
que nous sommes des femmes et des hommes
responsables nous allons dire oui
accompagnons le redressement mais
attention je veux préciser une chose les
collectivités locales investissent en
france à un niveau de 75 % + en privera
les collectivités locales de rentrée -
elles investiront vous leur direz
partira pas reparlé avec ce mot vous
êtes le premier investissement public
dans votre départ bien sûr évidemment
150 millions d'euros ce que vous pouvez
serrer les boulons g
les bouchons sont venus expliquer aux
téléspectateurs comment ça se passe
concrètement qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
vous ne pouvez plus faire par rapport à
la situation précédente et sur quoi
pouvez vous économisez concrètement par
exemple
non mais par je vais vous répondre
précisément mais par rapport à la
situation précédente
on peut faire la même chose puisque rien
n'est changé on devait avoir une baisse
de 2 milliards on a une baisse de 1
milliard et demi
c'est un peu moins c'est toujours trop
mais c'est un peu moins mais rien n'est
changé mais je les joue expliqué à vous
huriez devant la face à sarkozy quand il
voulait diminuer les dotations gestion
car bien sûr parce qu'il dit les
milliards et demi n'ont pas été diminué
il diminue et les dotations en montrant
du doigt les collectivités locales alors
que lui a creusé le déficit de 600
milliards d'euros en cinq ans record
absolu nous que pour les départements il
ya un problème essentiel c'est de
pouvoir continuer à payer la dépendance
si nous réglons le problème de la
vieillesse du troisième âge nous nous en
sortirons mais aujourd'hui près d'un
département sur deux ne sera plus
capable de payer
l'allocation personnalisée à l'autonomie
s'il n'y a pas une nouvelle loi
linde et annoncé qu'il n'a jamais été
dans tous les cas de problème
concrètement des économies dans votre
département
sur quoi pensez-vous les fins à bombay
sera légèrement l'investissement ça
c'est évident ils me permettent pour
permettre de tenir le fonctionnement
parce que dans un département
ça ça va obérer sur l'emploi non comment
un petit peu sûrement bien sûr c'est
bien simple parce que donc c'est pour
addiction vous comprenez bien oui mais
dans un département 65 % du budget ce
sont les allocations sociales et celle
là peut alors justement la cause encore
méconnu mais la cour des comptes dénonce
les dénoncent les niches sociales vous
estimez que vous croulez sous le poids
des aides sociales au niveau du départ à
namur exemple non le pot divo du
département c'est le rsa oui pour les
changements à l'insertion et la paix et
la paix a appelé lundi la dépendance
oui mais là dessus il ya rien à dire on
le modèle social français
c'est quand même de laisser personne au
bord du chemin refusé le congrès ce que
est ce que il faudra continuer à verser
la paix à aux personnes quelles que
soient leurs revenus ou est-ce qu'il
faudra le mettre en fonction des
ressources
le débat est ouvert et bien comme pour
les allocations familiales pourquoi pas
les débats sur la tam et des noirs est
sur la table pour refuser le maul vous
refusez le mot rigueur vous l'avais dit
il ya un instant est ce que vous estimez
que françois hollande a véritablement
tenu jusqu'à présent un discours de
vérité est ce qu il a fixé un cap clair
à vos yeux
mais bien sur wii le cap il est clair et
pour reprendre ce que vous disiez son or
que son orientation c'était le
changement maintenant le changement de
pratique le changement de politique
économique je pense en avoir parlé le
changement de politique sociale mais en
même temps comme son prédécesseur la
france étaient touchées de points de
plein fouet par la crise et cette
crise-là qui gronde dans l'europe
entière elle nous touche aussi donc le
cap de françois hollande
il est toujours là ce qui compte c'est
la trajectoire où nous voulons aller
mais nous allons aller moins vite pour
réussir parce que l'objectif si vous
permettez ces quêtes de réussir parce
que ce soit pour des raisons
politiciennes ou pas si la france ne
réussit pas à redresser ses comptes à
combler son déficit
ce sera une catastrophe et on se
retrouvera peut-être demain on se
retrouverait comme le niveau de la grèce
ou d'autres pays et nous ne voulons pas
que l'italie par exemple avec la poussée
du vote protestataire
on l'a vu aux dernières élections ni aux
dernières élections beaucoup
d'abstention beaucoup de votes extrêmes
il faut veiller à cela et pourquoi pour
combattre ces ces deux fléaux que sont
le vote extrême et l'abstention il faut
une politique claire que les français
comprennent pour l'instant ils ont un
petit peu de mal à la comprendre et nous
d'argumenter à nous d'expliquer et aux
gouvernements d'être clair dans ses
orientations
vous pensez qu'il n'est pas assez clair
non mais je pense qu'au jeu aujourd'hui
il n'est pas assez clair pour la bonne
et simple raison c'est que nous
attendons les chiffres du chômage et
qu'il va falloir mettre non pas une
réorientation ce serait idiot de dire
cela mais peut-être une inflexion dans
un certain nombre de passes à ses
chaussures à le faire est-ce qu'il n'est
pas assez courageux également avec les
réformes de structure on n'en a pas
parlé encore didier guillaume et même
chez des retraites
évoquant les lol
2 c'est du travail quand les ministres
latin midi ces cours de projet quand il
revient sur le jour de carence des
fonctionnaires bien suffisant à l'étude
c'est une très très bonne nouvelle pour
les fonctionnaires les fonctionnels les
fonctionnaires ont vu leurs revenus
baisser par rapport au secteur privé en
dit pas c'est parce qu on est dans le
populisme et ça c'est un retour sur les
fonctionnaires qui n'ont pas eu un seul
centime d'augmentation de salaires
depuis des années qu'ils n'auront pas
dans les années qui viennent alors c'est
symbolique c'est de leur dire si vous
êtes malade
en plus il ne faut pas le payer à dans
certaines entreprises
c'est le cas dans le privé pas dans
d'autres il faut le dire c'est
symbolique est ce que c'était vraiment
une réforme indispensable que sun
brouillent pas le message le cap tant
parlé d'un instant ça brouille quel
message sur les de dire qu'il faudra
faire des économies par milliards celui
de dire qu'il faudra redresser notre
pays dans la justice comme l'a fait ce
gouvernement avec le pact compétitivité
emploi parce que je vous signale quand
même qu'à donner le message est clair
mais le précédent quinquennat c'était la
loi tepa et le paquet fiscal
ce quinquennat là ces 20 milliards
d'euros d'allègements de charges
sociales pour les entreprises
ça ne s'est jamais produit ces dix
dernières années 20 milliards d'euros
d'allègements des charges sociales pour
les entreprises
parce que nous savons très bien qu'il
faut réhabiliter d'entreprise
réhabiliter le travail et que les
entreprises donc se développe à nouveau
il ya une grogne qui montre dans votre
pardon votre parti est parmi les
parlementaires qui remettent en cause
commencent à remettre en cause cette
austérité 7
sinon non mais ce n'est pas une grotte
il y à un débat madame
il ya là où situez-vous dans ce débat
moi je et je les dis très clairement
d'abord le redressement ensuite la
redistribution
si nous faisons linverse nous ne sommes
pas responsables
on a vu ce qui s'est passé il ya il ya
trente ans ce n'est pas position
redressons les finances besson le
faisant baisser le déficit et après nous
pourrons aller mais en même temps et
c'est là où je mets un bémol avant
propre raisonnement
c'est qu'il ne faut pas que les français
voient passer les trains et que les
trains ne s'arrêtent jamais c'est pour
ça que le redressement il doit être le
plus juste possible et c'est là dessus
que j'attends gouvernement je pense que
tous les français sans crainte tous les
français sont capables de comprendre que
la crise est là et qu'il faudra encore
faire des efforts mais peut-être les
salaires n'augmentent pas mais il sait
je pense je sais vous qu'ils espéraient
tour je pense qu'on pouvait avoir une
énorme grogne voire plus si il
s'apercevait que les efforts demandés
n'était pas justement répartis et c'est
ça la langue et une explosion sociale
il peut il peut dire déjà avec le
nouveau record du chemin il peut se
produire une explosion sociale tous les
jours je pense qu'il faut faire en sorte
que ce ne soit pas le cas en expliquant
la politique et en montrant la justesse
certains choix gauche tu es peut-être
même au sein du ps souffle sur les
braises selon qui l'un de vos
partenaires la du sénat dans l'est dans
un instant j en ai j'espère que non que
ce soit ceux de l'extrême gauche ou de
la droite de la droite parlementaire
l'enjeu il n'est pas celui ci les
élections auront lieu dans quelques
temps et chacun défendra ses arguments
mais aujourd'hui l'enjeu il est clair
est ce que la france est encore un grand
pays où est ce que la france va sombrer
et bien moi je fais partie de ceux qui
soutiennent complètement la politique du
chef de l'état et du gouvernement
parce que les orientations qui sont
prises vont dans le bon sens
malheureusement
malheureusement elles sont très
difficiles à expliquer parce que les
français n'en voit pas les répercussions
et immédiatement et moi je m'adresse en
aux français je vais leur dire
payet confiance en leur a tellement fait
le coup pendant des années ça ne prend
plus mais soyez sûrs que les
parlementaires qui soutiennent ce
gouvernement entend tendu la grogne la
souffrance les difficultés que vous
traversez et vont tout faire pour que
dans le redressement
les français que vous êtes ne voit pas
passer les trains sans qu'il s'arrête
alors vous avez dit il faut réduire le
déficit en arriver à ces 3 % c'est la
manière de préserver notre souveraineté
nationale
il avait deux ou trois ans un choix
mais pour autant on connaît les méthodes
pour y arriver vous le savez dit
guillaume un exemple il faudrait de
réformer à nouveau les retraites vous là
d'un mot vous êtes dit prêt à tenir ce
discours de vérité aux français et qui
partent désormais à 62 ans et quelques
mois il faudrait aller beaucoup plus
loin
non je ne suis pas prêt à mettre parce
que je suis pas prêt je pense qu'il
faudra sûrement en retrait retravailler
sur les retraites puisque la loi qui
avait été voté au parlement tout est
dans le rouge mais n'est pas financé
donc on sait bien comme pour l'assurance
maladie dont je rappelle qu'il ya
quelques années sous le gouvernement
jospin elle était à l'équilibré mais moi
je ne veux pas que l'on commence à
montrer du doigt les citoyens français
en leur disant c'est vous qu'est ce que
cela vous avez commencé à taxer les
retraites dans le derrière dans la
dernière note chinois mais évidemment
que lorsqu'on augmente les impôts pour
redresser parce que vous posez des
questions qui gérait mur mais
l'adversaire se montre du doigt
pertinente mais qui ont parfois
contradictoires vous nous dites il faut
faire des efforts pour voir plus de
recettes qui quitte les jeux où il
explique et en même temps faut pas trop
le faire non il faut le faire de façon
la plus juste possible il faut que cet
effort soit partagé il y aura des
efforts à faire peut-être pour les
retraités j'en serai mais il faut mettre
cela au débat mais moi ce que je ne veux
pas c'est que aujourd'hui un débat un
peu intergalactique ait lieu dans les
rangs de la gauche en disant plus ceci
plus cela tout à l'heure j'entendais mon
excellente amie et camarade emmanuel
maurel qui disait il faut faire autre
chose mais le jeu c'est quoi ces
dépenses et comment non faisons un pacte
ce pacte de compétitivité ce pacte de
confiance ce pacte de croissance
présenté par le gouvernement
il est clair il essayait pas d'autre
alternative que ce que vous faites est à
dire l autre on l'a vu à l'oeuvre
elle n'a pas marché et les français on
est certains chez vous libérez un peu de
pouvoir d'achat pour relancer la relance
oui mais il faut libérer un peu de
pouvoir d'achat peut-être lorsqu on peut
le faire ce que je constate c'est que
les parm dans notre pays n'a jamais été
aussi importante qu'aujourd'hui
donc il faut rétablir la confiance mais
s'il ya la confiance je pense que les
gestes qui peuvent redémarrer
martine aubry va déjeuner avec le
premier ministre
ce mercredi il a besoin de ses conseils
je leur souhaite un bon appétit
bon appétit j'espère qu'ensemble ils
travailleront bien que sur la même ligne
de loin la voix de martine aubry qui
compte sera une voix qui soutiendra le
parlement sans sais c'est pas un
événement quand même merci il ya que le
premier ministre reçoive les grands
responsables politiques
on va suivre ça attentivement merci
suzette perrine tarneaud donc de public
sénat arrive pour évoquer le sénat
maintenant avec vous didier guillaume
ces réformes certaines qui le concerne
bien sûr directement puis sa majorité
introuvable je le disais tout à l'heure
mais d'abord la question qui agite
beaucoup les esprits notamment parmi vos
collègues socialistes vous même la fin
du cumul avez vous concerne évidemment
directement alexandra colinot didier
guillaume a un agenda bien chargé
celui de premier vice-président du sénat
doublé de président du conseil général
de la drôme plusieurs casquettes et pas
des moindres pour la moche à pau de
feutre l'exemple même du cumulard comme
on les nomme vulgairement
mais l'homme et ses amis défendre
l'importance de son ancrage sur le
terrain il est issu d'un terroir il est
un enfant de la drôme de bourg-de-péage
sa vie le sont qu'en tant son
département der garde et didier
guillaume voudrait ce que c'est comme
élu de terrain
mais didier guillaume devra faire un
choix pour sa prochaine mandature
le projet de loi sur le non-cumul au
menu du conseil des ministres en mars
devrait interdire le cumul strict des
mandats
c'était la province numéro 48 du
candidat hollande
celle qui a toujours mécontenter les
barreaux ps du sénat
je comprendrais assez mal que on
ne permettent pas à des sénateurs d'être
responsables d'exécutifs locaux aura des
propositions d'amendements lorsque nous
connaîtrons le texte est pas le cas
aujourd'hui précis il y aura
certainement une discussion assez longue
et assez approfondies sur l'ensemble des
questions qui se posent à ce sujet autre
pomme de discorde la date d'application
selon l'avis du conseil d'état remis le
21 février le non cumul doit prendre
effet à échéance des mandats
parlementaire c'est-à-dire en 2017
mais seuls contre tous harlem désir
aimerait que la loi soit appliquée dès
au moment des municipales et propose un
référendum pour trancher la question de
l'agenda
voilà perrine tarneaud nous a rejoint
toujours ici au salon de l'agriculture
bonsoir bonsoir
guillaume alors françois hollande a
réussi une synthèse dont il a l'art
c'est à dire que la loi sur la
limitation du cumul sera certainement
voter d'ici la fin du quinquennat mais
avec une application en 2010 est est ce
que ce scénario vous vend ah non mais ça
ce n'est pas la synthèse de françois
hollande c'est la recommandation du
conseil d'état françois hollande projet
du gouvernement tel qu'il a été transmis
au conseil d'état comporter déjà la date
dont ce soit françois hollande est très
claire il avait dans son programme la
limitation du cumul des mandats ce qui
n'a jamais été fait jusqu alors sauf par
lionel jospin un peu cette loi cette loi
sera présenté en conseil des ministres
votée au parlement
après est-ce que c'est un débat une
polémique quant à son application le
conseil d'état dit 2017 pourquoi parce
qu'on ne peut pas raccourcir un mandat
en cours de parlementaires niera
toujours un nom d'ante non non pas du
tout pas du tout donc elles sont là une
fois qu'on aura fixé la date après le
mandat de parlementaire puisque sont
concernées les parlementaires ça veut
dire qu'au 1er janvier 2017
il n'y aura plus de mandat en cours et
donc les choses pourront se faire ce
n'est pas une trahison de la promesse de
françois hollande ce n'est pas durant le
quinquennat elle va s'appliquer dans le
alors ce qu'il a mais vous savez dans
les 60 propositions du candidat
elle devait pas tout s'appliquer la
première année c'est sur la durée de ces
cinq ans donc si j'allais dans la
facilité je vous dirais il ya d'autres
sujets nous là nous en avoir abordé les
blocs beaucoup plus importante bien sûr
mandat mais je vais répondre à vos
questions
est-ce que ce scénario avec ce scénario
vous pensez que le texte passera au
sénat et ce quart à une majorité pour le
oui je le crois
le tout c'est de savoir qu'est ce qu'il
y aura derrière le derrière le texte
qu'est ce qu'il y aura dans le si nous
pouvions parler tranquillement je vous
dirai tout simplement que c'est pas la
limitation du cumul des mandats qui
compte c'est la limitation du cumul des
mandats et des fonctions
si on pouvait parler tranquillement sans
démagogie etc
je vous dirais que ce n'est pas de cumul
des mandats qu'il faut parler mais c'est
de complémentarité je connais des
journalistes sont à la radio le matin la
télé le soir
ah c'est pas un cumul c'est des
complémentarités les effets personnes
mais en général je connais des élus qui
sont maires et députés c'est le même
métier
par contre ce qui ne va pas c'est quand
un grand pas trop de patrons de
laboratoires pharmaceutiques et membre
de la commission sociale de l'assemblée
nationale du sénat
ça ça ne va pas donc si on veut rénover
la vie politique
on sait très bien qu'il faudra passer
par le cumul des mandats la limitation
du cumul des mandats
lapsus révélateur par la limitation du
cumul des mandats
nous allons le faire je le voterai mais
je ne voterai pas une limitation du
cumul des mandats qui voudrait montrer
du doigt les élus et qu'il leur dirait
mandat de parlementaire unique ça serait
catastrophique
il faut un ancrage local harlem désir
lui il persiste et signe il veut la
limitation du cumul dès 2014 il a tort
harlem désir que je soutiens sans
réserve
je lui demande et je voulais dire harlem
concentre-toi consacre toi à la défense
de la politique gouvernementale et à la
promotion des orientations
gouvernementales après que le parti
socialiste dise c'est pour 2014 et
peut-être nous nous avons toujours dit
la loi toute la loi rien que la loi si
c'est en 2014 que le parlement vote et
qui a pas de censure ça sera appliquée
en 2014
moi je pense que la bonne date qui
permettra d'avoir une majorité à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat
c'est effectivement 2017 c'est pas pour
botter en touche mais c'est parce qu'à
la fin du mandat des députés à la fin du
mandat des sénateurs
eh bien on repart à zéro ce choix
personnel ce sera le cas à ce moment-là
je pense que 2007 c'est là c'est la
bonne formule
à la fin du mandat de deux sénateurs ou
de député
et là on choisit ses choix comme ça mes
questions j'ai beaucoup trop tôt la nuit
on verra je choisirais parce que je
voterai la loi oui je voterai la loi
limitant le cumul des mandats à
condition à condition que l'on met aussi
la limitation du cumul des fonctions
parce qu'aujourd'hui on en parle très
peu mais les fonctions de président
d'une grande agglomération d'une d'une
métropole avait dit tout à l'heure dite
et guillaume et vous pour vous vous
choisissez quoi entre votre parent
aimant de la drogue mais votre siège de
sénateur je verrai comment les choses se
passent
si j'ai le droit d'être vice président
ou pas si je peux être conseiller
général ou pas on verra bien ce n'est
pas d'actualité
alors beaucoup de questions et de
critiques ces derniers temps didier
guillon sur le président du sénat ce
matin encore un article dans le
quotidien le parisien on le juge trop
immobiliste trop silencieux pour
certains de vos collègues au sénat
est-ce que vous aussi vous êtes
impatients d'entendre un peu plus la
voix du président du sénat
en règle générale je ne suis pas
impatient parce que on m'a appris la
patience tout petit je pense que le
président du sénat a une voix qui porte
il a une voix qui porte auprès des
autorités publiques auprès du président
de la république qui doit régulièrement
auprès du premier ministre qu'il voit
très régulièrement
mais visiblement elle n'est pas entendue
jusque dans les couloirs du sénat
puisque notamment jean michel baylet qui
est le vieux copain de lycéens de jean
pierre bel le président du sénat indique
jean-pierre veille n'était pas en phase
avec sa majorité
écoutez elle est peut-être pas entendu à
certains endroits mais je sais par
exemple sur le cas des finances des
collectivités locales quand l'assemblée
nationale à l'effet de loi sur la
péréquation le président du sénat a
poussé un coup de gueule si je peux me
permettre
il a appelé qui de droit et les choses
vont être réformé dans les petites
communes soit oublié exactement
donc ce qui compte c'est pas forcément
d'être tous les jours à la télévision
dans les radios mais c'est de faire
centre avait pour l'hémicycle la
question se pose évidemment de
l'autorité du président du sénat sur
cette majorité que vous avez du mal à
composer
mais la majorité on n'a pas dû mal à
composer mais on sait très bien
qu'aujourd'hui c'est une majorité de
gauche de 6 sièges
mais que les communistes le groupe
communiste crc n'est pas dans la
majorité gouvernementale
donc il ne vote pas les textes le budget
non pas voter les textes européens et ça
on n'y peut rien ça c'est la politique
nationale c'est pas dans l'hémicycle
mais certains bons mais certains quand
même pointe un manque d'autorité
est ce que c'est le fait du président du
groupe socialiste au sénat où est ce que
c'est le fait du président du sénat mais
je crois qu'il travaille bien tous les
deux les accords politiques allemands de
transit selon vous les flics c'est le
président du groupe la gestion globale
du sénat c'est le président du sénat ils
pourraient bien ensemble je sais qu'on
fait cela j'ai lu l'article ce matin
d'ailleurs mangé ses trucs et très dure
vis-à-vis du président du sénat que je
connais bien que d'un ami de très longue
date mais il en va ainsi pense qu'on est
dans la politique faut accepter les
critiques et faire la preuve par
l'exemple
quand le président du cdh a créé les et
agir au delà de la démocratie
territoriale et que derrière sans suite
deux lois une sur le statut de l'élu
pour garantir leur statut et l'autre
pour limiter les normes et dont les
agriculteurs notamment n'en peuvent plus
ces sont des lois qui ont été pas qu'ils
sont inquiets été présenté qui ont été
votées vous l'avez rappelé y ait une
majorité très courte pour la gauche au
sénat du coup pour les sénatoriales de
votre objectif c'est de gagner combien
de sièges en plus notre objectif c'est
de concernés c'est de conserver un sénat
à gauche pour soutenir la politique
menée par ce gouvernement
on sait très bien qu'il n'y aura pas de
majorité absolue au sénat
tel qu effet le mode de scrutin
justement d'entre elles changé et alors
alors quand je vois par exemple jean
claude gaudin le président du groupe il
ya là ils vont égaler tendre la
proportionnelle ils sont comme ça d'un
coup d'un seul sur mes voire 5 à 10
sénateurs de plus de tripatouillage
électoral
je sais que l'ump est une spécialiste ès
tripatouillage électoral parce qu'ils en
ont coupé jt majorité touché mais alors
qu'aujourd'hui la question du sénat et
du mode du nombre de sénateurs à 3 pour
la proportionnelle
c'était la loi précédente elle a été
retoqué nous voulons la remettre qui
gagnera demain
en fait ce qu'on savait que le sénat
allait basculer à gauche permet du coup
des 10 km
les purifier les alliances avec les
verts ou avec le front de gauche donnant
privilégier les alliances avec jonathan
ils veulent la réussite du gouvernement
et qui veulent travailler dans une bonne
intelligence au dans la majorité du
sénat et nous verrons bien
le sénateur jean-noël guérini dit qu'il
a de quoi faire sauter le gouvernement
est ce que vous lui avait demandé des
comptes ou au moins des précisions je je
je ne sais pas de quoi il retourne j'ai
dû ça dans un article de libération il y
à quelques quelques jours mais si je
parlais certains ne serai pas ministre
dit votre votre collègue de bureau via
je ne suis pas ministre mais quand même
vous l'avez pas demandé des explications
sur ce qu'elle a voulu dire non est ce
que vous allez voter la loi d'amnésie
des faits connus pendant des mouvements
sociaux qui est en discussion demain au
sénat jean luc mélenchon a menacé le
groupe socialiste qui ne voteront pas
cette loi seront des cibles du medef et
m'en fais écouter jean luc mélenchon on
a vu ce qui s'est passé au delà des
élections il a fait un gros score en
fait il n'a pas été élu ni à
hénin-beaumont ni à la présidentielle et
il passe son temps à taper sur le
gouvernement et sur la gauche ce n'est
pas comme ça que l'on construit une
politique cohérente sauf s'ils en
veulent à construire sur les ruines de
ce qui existe aujourd'hui
donc oui pour répondre à votre question
nous allons la voter vous allez arrêter
oui tous les gens sport pas seulement de
jean du pin en change mais de principe à
jean luc mélenchon au père le sc nous
avons réfléchi la la cette proposition
de loi a été rejeté en commission des
lois parce que c'était la mère qui verte
à trop de choses et elle va être
légèrement amendée et nous allons la
voter les ce qui se passera au civil
continuera à se passer mais au pénal
lorsqu'on est dans une manifestation
et lorsqu'il n'y a pas de grandes
exactions ne peut pas être condamné en
fonction d'un militantisme ou d'une
manifestation et d'accuser les enlever
cette proposition noix les atteintes aux
biens ou aux personnes en 4 4 à sion ou
de dégradations c'est ça c'est comme ça
que ça pourrait se passer très bien le
mariage pour tous le texte arrive début
avril au sénat quelle est votre position
vous sur ce texte en moi je suis un
farouche militant de l'égalité et donc
j'essaierai d'intervenir à plusieurs
reprises de défendre de promouvoir le
mariage pour tous c'est indispensable
c'est l'évolution de la société
la gauche a toujours fait ces grandes
progressions nous devons le faire et le
mariage pour tous sera votée au sénat
avec plus de six mois d'avant serait
simplement
on évoquait l'alternance qui est
intervenu au sénat didier guillaume jean
pierre raffarin dans un réquisitoire
assez sévère pour nicolas sarkozy
considère que l'ancien président de la
république a fait cadeau du sénat à la
gauche parce que c'est votre lecture des
événements tout ce que je sais c'est que
lors des élections sénatoriales il y
avait un climat particulier c'est un
climat de défiance entre les élus locaux
et le gouvernement et le président de la
république lié à deux choses les
atteintes aux territoires les critiques
incessantes contre les élus et la baisse
des dotations
moi ce que je veux dire au président
hollande au premier ministre et au
gouvernement
attention que 2014 ne soit pas à fronts
renversés avec 2011 et il faut tenir
compte de cela non pas pour garder le
sénat ou ne pas le garder
tout simplement parce que les
territoires nous l'évoquions tout à
l'heure sont des territoires qui
investissent qui se développent et nous
sommes ici au salon de l'agriculture et
la ruralité compte et cette ruralité je
laime et je veux la demande a compris
comme un ado dit à françois hollande ne
fait pas cadeau du sénat à droite dans
la prochaine fois c'est des électeurs
qui votaient absolument merci didier
aumont vous libère ses nouveaux amis de
la drôme sur votre stand on déguste des
choses délicieuses merci à vous merci
père est né la semaine prochaine c'est
justement jean pierre raffarin qui sera
l'invité de preuves par 3 bonsoir à tous
et à très vite